yeah so um leo from berkeley i'm going
to be talking about thinking dsls for
massive visualization you'll see what
that means in a little bit
and i want to point out that a lot of
the demos i'll be showing here actually
with some other colleagues in my lab
amina torlock matthew torok
edward liu and then ross bodek who's
kind of the professor orchestrating some
of this stuff
and actually i believe in a lot of this
stuff so strongly that i'm actually now
that i'm leaving berkeley i'm actually
starting a company that will sort of
incorporate some of these ideas okay so
i think
before talking about what i mean by
thinking dsls i'd want to get a gauge
for what you guys
think is important so i picked out some
things i found interesting and i'm going
to see kind of
who agrees so who thinks virtual
machines have been in the past 10 years
have been a really cool
step forward and kind of excited about
it okay cool so that's like everybody
how about type level computation like
dependent types who thinks that's
awesome
all right cool we got we got clapping
some strong enthusiasm but like half the
hands
okay how about social computing like
stack overflow who thinks that's awesome
all right so now it's like the other
half of the hands okay
[Laughter]
um all right how about program synthesis
all right we've got some hands all right
how about who knows what program
synthesis is
okay so that's that's what i want to
change i want um i want you guys to be
as excited about program synthesis as i
am and in particular for the second half
the talk i'm going to be talking about
doing program synthesis for parallel
computing
but you know let's walk before we run so
i want to get you on the same page for
you know getting excited about what's
coming here so
today it looks like most of us are
programming without synthesis so let's
take a look at a common example of doing
regular expressions um to do some
you know text munching so what i'm
showing right here is said um
probably a lot of you have seen it like
the first half of it is let's
match some text in a text file i'm not
actually going to tell you what that is
but it's just some strange symbols and
then once we have the match we're going
to do
we're going to take the match and
replace the um the the matches so we're
going to kind of template the results
and kind of pretty print it so that's
what you'd write today you'd have to
remember what all these symbols are and
then you know
hopefully you're not programming with
somebody else who wrote symbols you
don't know
so let's look at a different way of
writing that program
so i'm just going to go to the command
line i just did a ls
let's let's pick out and let's write
some stuff about a file
and we're going to use synthesis to
actually do it by demonstration
so here i took a look at some files um
and let's see
let's write the regular expression for
stuff that whether something's a
directory or not
so i'm just going to take a look at that
first character i want the regular
expression to pull out the first thing
i'll hit the synthesize button and here
it is
so what that means is we want the match
which that's parentheses we want to pull
out a particular part and then we're
going to match whatever that first
character is like
that means anything now let's be a
little tricky let's look at the let's
try to find out if something's
executable or not
okay let's take our examples of our
files and hit the synthesize button and
here we go
um i don't know how many people remember
what this s means but that's actually
white space
so what that means is okay if we have
some white space
match the thing right before it so that
dot again okay so just wrote two regular
expressions pretty easily
so let's write a bigger one let's try to
get the file size
because let's try to be a little more
useful here
um okay and then 102
then i'm going to hit the synthesize
button like you know synthesis is
magical right so i should just get the
result like that as you just saw
uh-oh okay right maybe not um so
synthesis is great but you know there's
still we have to do some work so we
timed out
so but things we can provide we maybe we
can't get the file size but we can get
close let's try to get the thing right
before it
so let's try to pull out what that thing
is
we let it run and then bingo okay so
as long as you have something two white
spaces then the thing it matches
now the thing we're going to do is we're
going to use this as a hint to the
program synthesizer and so
one of the big kind of cool concepts
about program synthesis is
first of all we're outputting the
program as the result but also we can
have a program as part of the input
so i'm going to give it a hint let's
take an oops
it's taken a regular expression that
looked like the staff thing provide that
as a hint that we want something that
looks kind of like this
but go a little further so let's
[Music]
let's try that again so 0
6 1 2 102
hit synthesize it spins away and
hopefully it works
awesome okay and so what we saw is that
thing i just wrote down below is
this thing here and i was able to finish
the rest of the program
using that hint now i'm going to show
you something kind of cool
let's remove this hint let's run it
again
it's going to spin away
and still worked we got the same result
so no no big change but basically
same answer here and that into human
intuition i had of
maybe if i could give a program to get
it closer then it could
finish the result for me you can
actually bake that into the algorithm
and so you can actually give the hints
in different ways
i can give the hint as a program or i
can give the hint as just you know
another example that kind of gets you
part of the way there
and just to finish off this example
let's make it do something useful let's
like have it print out the file size
so for the rest one should print out
file size 0
last one file size 612
and 102 and then for the result like
we will say we'll give it some more
hands we want to print out the size and
then i don't really remember how
the replacement syntax works so i'll
just put a question mark and i'll try to
replace the question mark with something
useful it runs
it's kind of running slowly because of
this bit right here and uh
did it finish yeah and so here's the
template so
great we just synthesized a regular
expression for something actually
realistic in like i don't know
one minute so that's pretty cool
okay so let's go
on okay so what did i do underneath
um it actually did something really
really stupid and being stupid was
enough to be to be dangerous so this is
kind of cool
so the way i implement it is i basically
just enumerated a bunch of regular
expressions and then as soon as one of
them
passed our examples that was it and i
finished um
that was you know that took you know one
evening of coding i spent another
evening make it a little faster
and now in the synthesis community we
just have a big bag of tricks for doing
this type of thing
so for example if your text doesn't have
any numbers i don't need to synthesize
any regular expressions that have
the the slash the you know the character
uh lookup for it
so i'll just remove that from the
numerator with just the pre-pass
so that speeds up stuff exponentially
likewise you saw i talked about hints of
like okay if i have another example
maybe i can incorporate that to making
future progress
and actually i wrote another version of
this to even a lot of these
uh tricks i just showed you in the
previous page you can actually do
automatically like you don't actually
have to code up
the way i did it was i used this new
system we're working on called rosette
which i'm probably not familiar with
rosette but you might have heard of
racket which is the
um the kind of the next version of
plt scheme and it also on the side it's
also going to use something called
z3 which is called a it's an smt solver
which is kind of the next generation of
the sat solver and rosette will kind of
automatically let you work with both of
these so i'm going to show you how that
how that looks like so first the part of
the code i had a regular expression
generator
this is just kind of think of it as a
recursive function that'll just
based on the depth of the of an ast will
just generate bigger and bigger asts
so here's kind of that recursion and the
idea is that
for each level of the tree we'll kind of
non-deterministically pick a different
thing so for example for the leafs of
the tree
we'll pick random things maybe a
character number white space
stuff like that the trick is though that
instead of actually enumerating these
we're doing uh we're generating a
symbolic uh value
so instead of actually brute force
enumeration we actually
if we have the choose of x we actually
get a symbolic value and if you ever
apply a function to it you just get
another symbolic value and then
inside of the the interpreter is just
building up constraints it's not
actually
enumerating all the things and then what
happens is once we have this kind of
symbolic regular expression we want to
put some additional constraints of you
know matching it to the examples
so on the top here i will you know make
a symbolic
regular expression and then i'm going to
ask rosette to solve the regular
expression
subject to some constraints in this case
let's say i'm pulling and trying to pull
out
the first t from the name touring i want
to assert that the result of the match
is going to be t
and then i'm going to run the regular my
symbolic regular expression on the name
touring
and i run it through rosette and
underneath it'll
turn into sap to sap formulas and
various other kind of optimizations
and i'll get that same result as
actually you saw on the
on the web version um so that's
program synthesis and a kind of one high
level notion of it
and i want to kind of step back and back
and say
well is mission accomplished like we
generated regular expression
is this where we want to stop let's say
i put this into my code like are we
happy like now we could write it but
i think we're forgetting a very
important thing is basically you need to
be worried about this guy
which there's this excellent quote by
john woods where he asks
where he says always code as if the
person who ends up maintaining your code
is a violent psychopath who knows where
you live
and uh you don't want to show that guy
this like it's hard to write it's harder
to read
so the idea with synthesis is uh one of
the cool things is
it's not just a tool it's part of your
you want to put it into the code layers
so i can imagine wrapping up the
function action
functionality i just showed you into a
synthesized set function
and maybe we show the output of what we
expect to get but the key part is we
also as part of the code we show the
examples that led us to thinking that's
the correct code we'll show those input
output pairs
maybe the template hint and now when we
give it to another programmer
they just they will read the examples
and it's a lot cleaner
you might be worried about performance
where you don't want to outrun time
every time you run a regular expression
to run this
but you know we have compilers so just
do the synthesis at compile time and
this is now part of your code
and so this is a whenever you have a dsl
you should be asking well
should i put synthesis primitives into
this dsl to make it actually
you know not look like crazy symbols
okay and so i showed you one example of
a synthesis language i've actually been
doing a lot of
i guess what's called data science
programming now or data wrangling bunch
of different terms
used to be called i guess etl like
extract transform load
and i'm going to show you how synthesis
changes the various programming steps
here
so what i just showed you was let's say
we have a bunch of different files now
we know how to do the extract step where
it's basically just a bunch of
regular expressions to get useful data
like out of your log file or your csv
but once we have these data sources now
we have to combine it into sql
and we have to combine it into a
understandable format so we'll use
something like
sql and then once we have the data kind
of centralized in a nice format then
we want to actually do the data analysis
so maybe we'll do machine learning
i do visualization so i want to put it
into a visualization system
so i showed you how to do uh regex for
the first step
synthesize regular expressions but we
can also synthesize sql and i'll show
you
for the second half to talk how to do
visualizations so let's walk through an
example of doing the sql synthesis
so i'm again i'm at berkeley and
berkeley is a public school which
is you know it's great in some ways but
as a if you want to teach there
that means you could easily have
hundreds of students and so doing
something like
uh meetings with your students it
becomes
quickly hard to manage so the way we did
it is
we just put up as google's a google form
where we ask students you know what's
your name what time do you want to meet
and so now we had all our students sign
up to me except for the question is
which students do we sort of have to
harass to get into the office so with
the questions
which ones didn't sign up and so we want
to use synthesis to
generate the sql to do this so
now we actually have two data sources
one is the the google's form i just
showed you now we have all the list of
students who did sign up and we want to
somehow compare that to the list of
students in the entire class that we got
at the beginning of the semester so we
want to
just create the sql statement that kind
of shows
kind of the subtraction the difference
between these two and so we did exactly
that
where okay we look at the on the on the
right we look at this a set of students
who signed up
we want to filter those out of whatever
result we have like we don't want to see
those because they're already
good what we want to do is show we want
to take the students from the list of
all the students
and show the ones from there who did not
sign up
and so this turns into a notion of like
a positive example and a negative
example
or a counter example so we'll pick paul
janus in green from the set
of set of all students because she
didn't sign up so we want that in our
result
and we'll pick um who's this i guess
smith berkeley who did sign up and so we
want to filter him out of the results so
put them marking them as radis don't
show this guy
we hit the next button and again this is
real app but just i don't have internet
connectivity here so i didn't want to
step through it
um and then what we get out in about
just
70 milliseconds was that exact sql
statement which gives us the uh the the
set difference
and once more we get the sql statement
we can verify it there or we can just
look through
the actual result of the thing and see
that yes all these students were ones
who did not sign up
uh and this case again we actually
instead of doing the brute force we
used uh not actually that might have
actually been with rosette we
where we again we automatically turn
into uh sat solver formulas underneath
uh cool thing here about this is you
might be sort of wondering well
theo is showing you all these small
programs what about bigger programs like
maybe sometimes half the time in dsls
half the times i'm in c or something
and there's some kind of interesting
trends here that i think are worth
understanding so what i'm showing here a
plot is over the past
decade or so i'm going to kind of
compare a few things
so the first one is everybody in this
room should be happy about is the
median programmer salary on a log plot
like it looks kind of flat but actually
did go up and it looks like we're going
to keep going up so
that's kind of good but we're kind of
expensive
and likewise something we want to
compare this to is how much code that we
actually need to deal with
so i took one of the bigger projects out
there which is the linux kernel and i'm
showing
thousands of in terms of thousands of
lines of source code
and we see that over 10 years yeah maybe
goes up one magnitude and so we know
like
program salary goes up a little bit
amounts of code we have to deal with
goes up a little bit as well maybe a bit
a bit faster
but other things go up a lot faster and
those are where things get interesting
so the first thing is let's
take a look at the speed of the fastest
supercomputer and like every year we
come out with new supercomputers
and that's you know every what two years
it goes up magnitude
and so what that means is essentially
brute force search
eventually if this keeps up will
actually let you
kind of hit the hit the barrier of code
size
so that's already that was the first
example i showed you regular expressions
and the second cool thing here is we
should look at sat solvers which is what
we're using
if you want to kind of automatically do
a lot of these search heuristics
one way to measure sat solver
performance is to look at how many
thousand variables it can solve
and so i actually i just did two data
points in drew line but in the beginning
about 10 years ago you could do about a
thousand variables using a sat solver
and now you can do uh what is this one
two three four four magnitudes more
variables
um and so that's that that's pretty
promising it's kind of matching moore's
law which is
kind of neat and so what that means is
uh not only do we get the brute force
but we also get smarter algorithms and
put those together
we're getting we're able to do bigger
and bigger code
so i don't want this talk to be a bait
and switch so uh
i talked about thinking dsl so i think
we're now kind of on a similar page for
what i mean by
program synthesis so now i want to turn
over to how we're using this for
enabling new types of visualizations and
so kind of a
back story here is one lesson from my
phd was that
trying to write a multi-core browser in
c plus manually is uh
that takes a few years and so as an
offshoot of that work i started making
some languages
language work to automate that process
to write a lot of that parallel code for
me
and what i'm going to be showing you
here is actually an offshoot of that
project
where instead of asking you to install
the multi-core browser that i was
building and actually
be able to deploy in today's browsers
and sort of the place deploy as a
library in
parallel javascript so let's
let's go through another demo just so
you know what i'm trying to achieve here
so here we go okay so here i'm showing i
was actually just
running stock safari and i'm just
showing actually sequential
visualization
using normal javascript and canvas and
this is the stuff that you might be able
to do today
if you wanted to what i'm showing you
here is
actually election data so 100 000
polling stations
unfortunately i can't tell you from who
like there's just various contractual
obligations here but it is a pretty
suspicious election um
and what you're seeing here is for each
one of these little squares like this
red one over here
that represents one polling station the
more red it is the more they voted for
the incumbent
so here they voted for incumbent the
more white it is like i don't know if
you have a nice white square somewhere i
don't know one of these squares they
voted for some other party
and as you zoom out you see that most of
the country uh is actually kind of
pinkish
it's actually the the size of each
square represents how many people voted
so actually here's a white one right
here and it's kind of small so it's a
small district
i mean small town and what you can see
is that i arranged it into
a district's base
and so you can see this is a bigger
district than that district for example
so one way that uh people look for fraud
in an election and one of kind of
the first things you do is you just look
at voter turnout like you expect you
don't expect to have 100 voter turnout
that means like you know the president's
voting for you or something like that
so let's let's i set up this uh i don't
know if you guys seen the bottom this
uh slider it's just normal jquery so i'm
gonna
um filter the data points based on voter
turnout
so here we see is all the towns that had
a voter turnout of about
twenty to forty percent maybe let's look
at towns where the voter turnout was
sixty to eighty percent
so okay more more people voted turned
out at sixty to eighty than at
uh twenty to forty but you saw that
normal browser this is kind of
a little slow right like that's not i
don't know
if i was a company i wouldn't want to be
showing my data analysis this way
and people defer on that but uh so here
i'm actually
using the same visualization actually i
i have a compiler
that spit out the plain javascript
version but i also i spit out
a gpu accelerated version just from the
same the same source files
and so let's do that same thing let's
take a look at
here are the towns that voted in 20
to 40 percent and then let's try to ask
a question like
um what's what's the biggest voter
turnout like where did most people
was the typical turnout for this country
and so most people turned out in 45 to
65
so if you're actually very curious you
can probably figure out which country
i'm talking about just by this statistic
so it's kind of cool
um but we're looking for fraud right and
so the thing you really want to look at
is let's take a look at all the
the places that turned out i don't know
in the
yeah let's do 80 to 100 uh turn out so
here are all the towns that probably
some suspicious like ballot stuffing is
happening because too many people turned
out
so what we're going to do is we're going
to highlight
um all of those uh in black
so take all those suspicious ones and
now what we do is we're going to zoom
back out
and this starts to be a little cool it's
like a little cancer spreading through
the country where we know
some parts of the country are entirely
suspicious others are kind of
you know in between while others look
pretty okay and those are generally this
more
voting for the um not for the incumbent
so i'll do one last step here i want to
point out that right now the the
the ruling party won by a nose here it's
like 50
so if we take all those suspicious ones
instead of just throwing them out let's
replace them with exit poll data
okay so now the incumbent's lost so that
means the
other parties if they formed a coalition
they could have um overthrown the
incumbent
so this is kind of this pretty
significant stuff and they probably
could have just done it by going through
a few districts
okay so i want to point out a couple
things more about the technology going
under underneath here
first part is you know i'm still showing
all 100 000 data points and you can do
the normal gpu type stuff
you know pan and zoom but the kind of
cool thing is i'm also doing this
filtering in real time
and so that means i have to really relay
it out as well i'm not just rendering so
this is
not the normal webgl stuff you see okay
let's jump back here so in particular i
want to point out three things that
kind of i think are important about this
system and why i've like i've been
putting time into being able to code it
it's the first part is i'm able to show
two to three magnitudes more data
without kind of
killing the experience so if you're like
again if your data company this is
actually pretty significant for what you
can
show to your customers the second part
is once you have that performance you
actually do new types of visualizations
i was just showing you how to do a tree
map but i've actually already invented
one new type unfortunately i don't have
time to show you but it's
it's it's creating new possibilities for
how we can explore these data sets so
that's
pretty cool um last bit and this is a
little thing a little more obvious stuff
is like okay
instead of writing it all in like raw
webgl we can use you know high-level
languages it's deployed on the web which
means that we can run on different
browsers we could share it whatever
but at the more high level i think those
first two points are like kind of what's
fundamentally different independent of
the platform
okay so the last bit i want to talk
about before i jump back into what
synthesis has to do with it and which is
i'm guessing i want to talk about this
because otherwise people will probably
ask is how did i
what's the actual guts underneath um the
idea is it sort of
looks like a normal browser so let me
get a little pen
here so in normal browser you get a
bunch of html and css you download from
the network
and then all of a sudden you run through
a bunch of native c plus plus components
like you're going to parse the files
once you know what the what the dom tree
looks like you're going to want to say
run your css selectors for example take
all the pictures and give them really
thick borders something like that
now that you have pictures with thick
borders you're going to have to kind of
relay everything out because you're
going to say oh i need to
give it a lot of space because the
borders are really thick and once we
know
where all the elements go and what size
then we can render it
normal scene graph type stuff so
essentially we're just outputting a
bunch of pixels
and now we can put it to the screen so
this is pretty simplified you know
javascript's there somewhere
the cool thing what we do is instead of
relying on the the normal browser's
native components because we can do
parallelism
we could do better so the idea is we
actually ship a
javascript library that sort of emulates
the um the normal browser components and
again instead of shipping a web page we
write
some different dsls that kind of look
like normal web dsls
and we'll run them through compiler to
just make things a little easier
the basic idea is like the stack looks
similar but parallel so we're gonna have
a
parser.js except for now it's gonna use
workers to be multi-core
we're gonna and after that we're
actually gonna dump it all into the gpu
and actually not only just do parallel
implementations of all the components
we're actually running them
the entire animation loop on the gpu
that's a big deal because if we're
dealing a million data points in real
time you don't want to be shipping that
between the cpu and the gpu
in like every second or every round
through the interactions
and so we'll have our select engine our
layout engine we're using something
called webcl i'd love to talk to you
after about like what that means
and then more for the rendering step the
more uh traditional use of webgl for
that part
and again i want to stress that it's
important that we're not just doing uh
acceleration for the rendering but we
have to hit the other parts as well
where we just be bottlenecked entirely
on those
so in terms of getting back in terms of
context of the talk the important parts
are two-fold one is to actually be able
to write parallel code for all this
stuff we're actually using dsl so it
just makes the problem more manageable
and then for the layout in particular we
wanted to make it really expressive and
here i'm using
synthesis to actually let us do that so
let's let's walk through that the layout
detail that uses synthesis
so the task is actually
we call it the fast tree language this
is our dsl and the task is similar to
what you'd actually have today on a web
page
where we have our data which is a tree
for example maybe has a horizontal box
somewhere
and the layout language is supposed to
figure out what goes where so in the
case of a horizontal box he has to
figure out that
the width of the overall box is the sum
of the two child widths
and the way we do this is actually it's
kind of like css except for we want to
do things you can't do in css like for
example maybe we don't want boxy layouts
we want like a radial
you know putting stuff around a circle
so we're going to want to add the
ability to
describe constraints and this is
something kind of formally equivalent to
something called an attribute grammar if
you're familiar with css and constraints
think of it that way
if you're familiar with that through
grammars think about it that way
so as an example of writing a this let's
say you wanted to find your own hbox uh
widget and this is sort of like how you
do it in css but a little different
um we'll say okay let's take the hbox
nodes
and then we're going to say that oh
maybe in the document we expect the x
and y attributes to be provided
and then as part of the constraints
works we're going to try to solve the
width height and maybe
radius i don't know why i have a radius
here but like
css doesn't have that or like a radial
layout so maybe we can add in things it
doesn't have
and the idea is then we're just going to
write constraints so for example for the
width
normally in css you just say like 50
pixels or 100
but here we can actually say width of a
box is the sum of the left with and the
right width
and so we'll write all those out and
this is
pretty much like the almost entire
language is a bit more the the key part
is that it's
there a couple of constraints on our
restrictions on the language the first
part is even though i give you the
ability to write these formulas
they're a little bit restricted
basically they have to be local so if
you're talking about
the widths they could only be about the
widths of the parent nodes or the child
nodes so kind of that
same region of the tree and the second
thing is actually again if you know css
you're kind of you're used to this
you can only define a constraint once
you can't define some
the width to be both 50 and 100 of the
parent um like that's we're already used
to that today
in this case i'll actually flag that as
a at the compile time as
an error that you know your constraints
don't make any sense but otherwise
it's kind of business as usual so using
this
dsl we've actually been able to do a
bunch of stuff that normally you'd have
to go into javascript for but now you
can stay in our dsl
and so then kind of this enrich css i'm
going to point out two particular ones
so on the bottom left you're seeing
actually not just a 2d visualization
you're seeing a 3d visualization
and so this one was very useful if you
have you know time series data like a
bunch of stock charts like hundreds of
those and you want to kind of quickly
see get a feel for what's going on there
and if you're just in normal it's a 2d
plot
it'd just be crazy the one on the top
right is also kind of cool
you might recognize that as wikipedia
and so we actually
specified the css language itself like
formally specified css
using this dsl i just showed you and now
actually mozilla
is working on a new browser that's using
kind of the concepts i showed you here
where we found parallelism in that in
the css layout language and they're
using that to build a new layout engine
and so that's kind of cool okay so
getting
so let's get closer to synthesis so i
showed you we have
you can write our layout in our dsl you
want to run it through our tool and
we're going to spit out parallel
javascript
a question you should be wondering right
now is well what does that
parallel javascript look like whenever
you're talking about synthesis is very
important what the output language is
because that kind of controls your
ability to actually
generate good code so luckily in
parallel in the parallel computing
community we've kind of settling on this
notion of parallel patterns that if
you're doing high performance algorithms
you'll just talk about
you know different patterns if you're
doing compilers you can say oh these are
the patterns i support
and this kind of rubric and so here
actually just show you some examples so
for
um most people here should be familiar
with mapreduce so that's
in a sense that's a pattern about the
data dependencies between your tasks
and but there are a whole bunch of other
ones in the case of layout languages
we're
interested in tree traversals and so
here i'm going to show you how you
actually do a layout engine
as a tree traversal again this is the
type of thing that we want our
synthesizer to reason about
so in this case we're going to do our
little language of horizontal boxes in
three traversals
so in the first reversal we're going to
solve all the width and height
attributes for every node
and so we'll do a traversal bottom up as
soon as we know the width and height for
the children of a node we can compute
the width and height for that node and
so we just do this recursively
and then once we have all the widths and
heights we can compute all of the x and
y coordinates
and this will be top down traversal over
the trees that means once we know the
position of one node we can go off and
compute the positions of
its children and we just recur and you
can do this for however many tree
traversals you want
and kind of for different types of
visualizations you probably have
different ones uh there are two
important parts here the first one
is that within each traversal there's a
lot of a lot of juicy parallelism
because these trees could be really big
so for example that first reversal we're
kind of going bottom up and you can view
at the bottom of the tree we have a
bunch of threads
and whenever those threads finish then
we can compute the parent of those
threads it's kind of a logical join
likewise maybe it's a little simpler to
understand is for the the second
traversal we're kind of going top down
through the tree
whenever we compute the x and y
attribute for one node we can do a
logical fork
and we run different threads for
different parts of the tree below and
you can kind of do this all the way down
i'm going to point out that here this
i'm just talking about identifying the
parallelism the computation this isn't
necessarily how we run it but when we
give it to the runtime now it knows kind
of the pattern of parallelism there and
it could do a lot of cool optimization
so i'll get to that
the second cool thing here is again
we're doing this offline you can think
of this as
you know when you're compiling your
browser or when you're compiling your
javascript library in like minute like
part of the minification step something
like that
so we will find a schedule we want to
find a schedule offline such that no
matter what
data set we push through let's say we
put in different election data that the
same schedule is still safe this is the
correct way to paralyze it
okay so now uh just make this like make
sure that's very clear there's actually
this notion of a schedule is an actual
real object in our system
so um kind of walk through a little
quickly
let's get that pinned back so here what
i'm saying is there are
two traversals to do this language of i
guess horizontal and vertical boxes so
the first traversal is
uh bottom up so there's this arrow here
and
when we when it visits a vertical box
node in our in our tree
we'll compute first the width attribute
and then the height attribute and same
thing for the horizontal box we'll
compute the width attribute and then the
height attribute so it's kind of a
schedule
and the idea is what's actually run
there we just go back to
our like our css that we wrote before
that normal constraint stuff
so for the horizontal box when you hit
the width we just run that with
computation
and in this case we have two two
traversals so you do one semicolon which
sort of waits
and then until that one finishes and do
the next
and once we have this pattern um and i
think i'm like really hammering this
home but like i really want you guys
thinking if you think parallel computing
you better be thinking patterns so
i don't feel too guilty about this so
for
to do a tree traversal on a gpu
there um kind of two things we want
there were two reasons actually we want
to do it the first one is we just want
lots of parallelism so
gpus generally can support more
parallelism than other parts of your
hardware today
and the second part is because we want
to do other parts on the gpu you never
want to move the data off the gpu you or
you want to keep it there in a pipeline
as long as possible
so it's we want to we want we do want to
map the computation down
so in this case we're just let's say
we're doing a bottom up tree traversal
we do something pretty simple it has a
fancy name of level synchronous breadth
first but conceptually it's pretty
obvious
you take the last level of the tree we
do parallel four loop over compute all
over those
once all of those are we compute all
those we have all the information we
know to compute the next level
run another parallel for loop etc and
just go all the way up the tree level by
level
so that's easy peasy um the where the
hard part really comes in here is that
gpus the memory is all weird like it's
it's cindy it's vector
it's um it's really these are all
synonyms for painful uh
don't don't put that on record um so
what we really need to do is you have to
do something called flattening and so
let's take our tree again and
remember uh we our each node has a width
height x and y
attribute so actually first of all we
want to take a tree we want to put it
into arrays because gpus love arrays
and one really important part here is
that on a level of the tree all the
nodes are next to each other so that
when we do the for loop
it's really just burning through an
array and the weird thing is actually it
has to burn through a bunch of arrays
so if you a node has four or four
attributes like maybe we're solving the
width height and x and y
we can't actually put those all next to
each other as one object we have to
split into a bunch of arrays and so
we this becomes very crazy coding and
this is why
like all the shader people don't really
like data structures and things and
it takes forever be nice to your graphic
designer
so the cool thing is whoops is that our
because we're using a dsl we can just do
all these transformations automatically
that's like compilers are awesome
so getting back to synthesis like now
that you know the code i want to
generate um and we want to
what the real challenge we found is
actually writing those schedules
and imagine we have some magical
automatic parallelizations thing that
will come out with that schedule for us
that's actually not enough so let's say
i made that tree map
but then i have a version of a version
bump because you know we're always
innovating
so if i do a little change to the
constraints i might introduce some data
dependencies
and so how i schedule it might have to
change a lot and actually
it might be really bad how i change it
maybe it's a bug in the and how i change
the the spec because it just kills the
parallelism
and so the idea is instead of just
having the schedule be the output of the
compiler
we also want the schedule to be the
input so this is kind of weird
and i'm going to walk through an example
of what this means
so here i'm showing actually the
schedule for the css
multi-core css layout engine i'm
actually not showing all of it like you
see i have all these underscores where
i'll say do a bottom up traversal but
then i do underscore and i don't really
specify the rest
and this is what synthesis gives you
it's like it lets us only specify parts
of the program that we care about
so in this case by me not saying what
actually gets computed in a traversal
i could say oh let me trust the
synthesizer to
pick pick those so if i change the spec
and all of a sudden the width and
heights can't be computed in the first
traversal
like the the one over here maybe now
they have to be
computed later in this uh i guess fourth
traversal
because i left an underscore there i
meant i gave the synthesizer the freedom
to move those computations
however there are other and that's great
so now i don't have to worry about that
type of parallel computing
but there are other cases where i don't
want the schedule to change so for
example
if we look at these last few traversals
they're parallel which is great which is
the whole point of this exercise
however if i change the the constraints
i might introduce a data dependency
there
where for example now they have to be a
sequential computation because it just
has to be recursive tree traversal or
something like that
the synthesizer will actually reject
that change so say oh you changed the
you changed your layout widget in a way
that breaks the parallelism
or the way you intended the parallels in
parallel to work
and this is this is kind of deep so my
kind of claim here is that
just as we have to come up with
structured a structured approach to
sequential programming
i'm claiming this is sort of a
structured approach to parallel
programming
where and here's some examples of how we
used it if i needed to share a
visualization with one of my co-workers
or one of my colleagues
i didn't want him to break the
parallelization scheme so this helped me
share code with them and let me
communicate the parts that were
important
likewise when i was trying to work with
just on my own to figure out how to
paralyze something i was able to test
ideas i could leave holes and let the
synthesizer see what it could do
likewise if i expected it to do
something but it couldn't it became a
debugging tool
this all just by letting me kind of
sketch these schedules
okay so kind of getting close to
finishing up here i want to
leave you with a couple of thoughts so
the first part is
i've shown you doing synthesis for a lot
of the steps and languages used for data
science and data programming you know
like the regular expressions the the sql
and
like how to build these like high
performance visualizations but
we've actually our group and others have
also been looking at a lot of other
domains
so here's some ones that like i can talk
to you after about if you're interested
in
but i want to point out a few really fun
examples so the first one is synthetic
biology
so if you build a biology circuit the
output is something like
tylenol or i don't know biofuel like
these are things we would like to be
able to generate right
and what the program is is actually the
protein activation network
and so now the synthesis task is to
figure out what is the
um what is the synthetic biology the
protein network that we want to build
such that we can generate
uh biofuel or tylenol or you know cheap
drugs or something
the next one is on the next row is on
user interface layout
so i showed you how to build the kind of
low level kind of schedules for it
but the question is how do i write the
the kind of the css and the constraints
to begin with
and there you again you'd like to do
stuff by example and so we've actually
have some cool stuff
and the last one i think will appeal to
the maybe to the strange loop crowd
especially which is type systems where
nowadays if you're building a type
system you probably want to start with
ml
like if not you probably have a good
reason not to do that but because you're
designing a new language there's
probably something really cool about it
and you're probably
if you would like to encode some of that
knowledge in the type system and check
some extra interesting properties
but that could get really hard and we
have like you know history of just
broken type systems in production
languages
and so the idea is here just how i had
to put in question marks and underscores
for stuff i wasn't sure to put in
it'd be nice as part of your type your
type system you just put in well i need
to have some sort of type rule here
and then i'll figure out what the rest
is and i can point you to a pretty fun
example here that we're working with
recently for some
pretty security critical stuff and so
with that i want to
finish with the last thought which is um
one way to think about synthesis
languages is that a lot of times we're
programming it sort of feels like we're
working for the
compiler but that's kind of like
backwards so
don't do the compiler's work like use
program synthesis
all right thank you